To recap today's lesson, data science is a discipline
that incorporates methods and expertise from a variety of different
fields, to glean insights from large data sets, and then
use those insights to build data driven products, or to
create action items. There's no cookie cutter way to become
a data scientist, but a lot of data scientists have
a very strong background in mathematics and statistics, and also
have the programming skills to handle these data sets and
also to perform analysis. Currently, data science is most closely
associated with the tech field, but more and more data
science is being used all over the world in a
variety of different fields. In order to solve new and
old problems, more efficiently and effectively. Now I know what
you're thinking. This sounds awesome, data science sounds really cool,
I want to work on a project get me some
data. Unfortunately, data seldom comes in formats that we want.
It might be in a format we've never seen, it might come from a
weird source. There might be missing or
erroneous values. Because of this, any data
scientist worth their salt is skilled at
acquiring data. And then massaging it into
a workable format. That's what we're going to be covering in the next lesson.